you were writing about income inequality
before income inequality was cool on net
do you think thomas piketty's book has
been good or bad for the debate I think
it's been positive for the debate I
think it's hard to find a book at
economics that attracted so much
attention and that by itself is good I
think it produced a lot of very
interesting data it provides a
provocative theory I think it misses the
main reasons for the rise in inequality
and misses the main reason why I think
inequality will likely continue to grow
but nonetheless I think it was positive
for the country to have this debate and
the main reason Allen being well if you
look at what's happened to the bottom
ninety nine percent it's a lot more
significant than frankly the top 1%
pulling away from everybody else there's
been an enormous increase in inequality
along educational lines along other
lines associated with the bottom ninety
nine percent if you look at college
graduates versus high school graduates
we've seen a huge shift in inequality
and that has contributed the grand
scheme of things much more to the rise
in inequality and I think that's likely
to feed on itself we're seeing something
of an inequality trap coming through
human capital not through financial
capital which is what Piketty argued the
advantages for the wealthy are much more
likely to be passed on to their children
through investments at home through
connections that they have in the
workplace and I think that's been
contributing to this kind of inequality
trap where the inequality builds on
itself it makes it much more difficult
for children backboard to disadvantage
parents to move up it has been ever thus
though has it not Alan this idea that
people who are sort of trapped in
low-income pockets of ikana the economy
can remain there for a long time and the
dynastic wealth over time just creates
more and more wealth what about some of
the other factors that are going in your
mind that are going to increase
inequality in the next several years
well it's absolutely right that we've
had a lower social mobility than we like
to think as a nation
but I think that situation is going to
get worse and we see the seats of that
being sewn already we see for example
gap growing in the likelihood that
children participate in extracurricular
extracurricular activities we see a gap
growing between children born to
disadvantaged and advantage families in
terms of the amount of tutoring they get
in terms of the amount of total years of
education they get right most of the
expansion in higher education has taken
place among the top 50% and that's going
to feed on itself and make it even
harder for children to move up from the
bottom Alan I want to take the other
side of the argument though right okay
so for the moment here I want to bring
up I'm not sure if you're going to be
able to see this but we have a chart
here from the CBO who has done their own
you know they've obviously crunched data
on income over the last several decades
and there's one chart where from 1979 to
2010 yes it shows that for the top 1%
income has grown tremendously and
outpaced the bottom the bottom ninety
nine percent but middle incomes during
that period they've are the CBO wrote
were up about forty percent so it wasn't
as if their wages were stagnant or
declined and yes for the top 1% it rose
but there were also moments where the
incomes for the top 1% declined and they
declined in both Republican and
Democratic administrations so if this
isn't this is essentially a problem in
you know for both political parties but
it also shows that perhaps that wage gap
is more fluid and flexible than it has
been it's in the last several years and
it's not any worse Alan in some ways the
social mobility not any worse than what
we've seen in other parts of the world
well in equality has been growing in
many parts of the developed world but
it's increased much more in the US and I
think it's a problem for the country I
think it's a problem for both Democrats
Republicans independents people who
don't vote and what we've seen is as I
said before the 98th percentile is
pulling away from the median
97th percentile is pulling away from the
median and the median has pretty much
stagnated we've had periods where the
bottom 10 bottom twenty percent so
enormous declines in their income after
inflation at twenty percent drop for for
the bottom ten or twenty percent from
the late 70s until the early 1990s so
you're right it's fluid except it's not
moving in the right direction and this
is a trend that's been taking place for
over three decades now Alan you like a
lot of critics of piketty's book have
praised the data that he pulled together
but argued with with with his
explanation of the data what I'm
wondering is and I thought it was
fascinating how the book took income
inequality all the way back to the
Gilded Age and then in France all the
way back to pre-revolutionary France is
there a value to these historical
comparisons or they just throw it off
and we think about Gatsby hahaha uh well
I think they're two different things in
that I think the data that we have once
the income tax started are pretty
accurate I think going back two hundred
three hundred years there's a tremendous
amount of speculation that takes place
and certainly since the 1940s since the
current population survey started we
also have household survey data which
are pointing in the exact same direction
so I think there's a wealth of data
indicating that the last three decades
for the US have been unusual and as I
said before inequalities increase in the
number of countries but it's increased
to a greater extent in the u.s. than
just about anywhere else